Journey to new heights.
A unique global destination driven by cutting-edge technology in Neom.
This is Trojena.
Breathtaking architecture and innovative engineering...
...folds seamlessly into the natural landscape.
Ascend to a vertical village, a portal connecting the digital and the physical.
The seasonal climate provides a multitude of high altitude adventures...
...in the Arabian Peninsula...
...with the region's first outdoor ski experience.
Enjoy the buzz of world-class entertainment,...
...the crisp mountain air and the world's most advanced health and well-being center...
...nourish both body and soul.
And as night falls, you can witness the stars as you've never seen them before.
Welcome to Trojena,...
...the mountains of Neom.